what the language acquisition experts
with the exception of saving crashing
what they try to do is describe it's as
if language learning is a motion picture
and they're going to describe it frame
by frame
uh or even not a motion picture but a
animated cartoon where every little step
every little possibility is explained
whereas actually is a very simple
natural phenomenon it's the process of
acquiring new language habits largely
through a lot of listening and reading
and the kind for example I don't want to
pick on this one because this Rod Ellis
second language acquisition is in many
ways the best of all these books because
it's short and sweet not as good as
crashing who has a number of very short
books explaining language acquisition